so it's time that we have a serious
level-headed conversation about the
topic of UFO phenomena that's right
aliens have they visited planet Earth or
not in this video I'm going to outline
three specific mass UFO sightings
witnessed by thousands of people and at
the end of this you're going to have to
ask yourself well either it's aliens or
top-secret technology that's been
suppressed from the masses for several
decades now before I get into those
three cases let me first ask does anyone
else find it interesting that well say
President Obama in the beginning of his
term he stated that he had no knowledge
of UFO visitation planet earth then he
said he didn't know and then just a
couple years before he left office he
says I can't reveal anything
in fact former President George W Bush
said the same thing earlier this year
I'm not saying nothing like why not just
say I don't know or no but to say I
can't reveal anything or I'm not saying
anything like I don't understand
especially in the case of Obama who was
president at the time I who's your boss
we mean you're not allowed to say
anything I did I miss read the
Constitution and who's really in charge
hmm
but they're not the only presidents to
have discussed this in fact Jimmy Carter
back when he was governor he had a UFO
sighting he sawed himself and there was
even a sworn statement to prove it or
even take president Ronald Reagan when
he was governor of California
he had his pilot follow a white orb and
after a few minutes he said quote it
shot up to the heaven straight into
outer space like what is that about and
it's worth mentioning that even Mikhail
Gorbachev who was the president of
Russia at the same time as Reagan made a
similar comment about the existence of
UFOs even take Paul Hellyer the former
defense minister of Canada who was even
acting prime minister at one point that
has stated publicly on numerous
occasions that yes aliens are visiting
earth there's multiple species one of
which you could walk down the street
right next to and you have no idea that
they were an alien which raises all
kinds of questions
now whether you believe these people or
him I mean that's a whole different
story what do I know but it is
interesting but they're not the only
ones guys take John Podesta chief of
staff for Bill Clinton chiefest
for President Obama chief of staff for
Hillary Clinton during her campaign just
during this last election he is say that
his greatest regret was not being able
to release UFO FILES now that could be
just some political thing to try and get
votes for certain people but I mean he
has spoken about it on numerous
occasions and he is certainly a
Washington insider so I mean take what
you want from that comment but there
have been astronauts that have talked
about this take for example the late
Gordon Cooper who is a mercury astronaut
who wrote about this in his own book by
the way I know other astronauts share my
feelings we know the government is
sitting on hard evidence of UFOs even
went on to say in reference to the
Roswell UFO incident I had a good friend
at Roswell a fellow officer he had to be
careful about what he said but it sure
wasn't a weather balloon like the Air
Force cover story he made it clear to me
that what crashed was a craft of alien
origin and members of the crew were
recovered or even take the late Edgar
Mitchell I mean this gentleman was a
stand up character I recommend you
listen to the interviews on him and his
thoughts on spirituality and the cosmos
and everything else his views differ
much from mainstream sciences just say
that but he did say I happen to be
privileged enough to be in on the fact
that we have been visited on this planet
and the UFO phenomenon is real it has
been covered up by government for quite
some time now in fact he even went on to
say that aliens have contacted humans
several times but governments have
hidden the knowledge or truth for 60
years or even take this last quote press
pause read it I'm going to actually go
into it later in this video but posit so
you can read it on your own for the sake
of brevity but the list goes on mercury
astronaut scott Carpenter and no time
when the astronauts were in space were
they alone there was a constant
surveillance by UFOs or even astronaut
Brian O'Leary for nearly 50 years the
secrecy apparatus within the United
States government has kept from the
public UFO and alien contact information
we have contact with alien cultures now
whether you believe these people are
their stories that's on you I mean what
do I know but it was worth sharing so
let me jump into now these math UFO
sightings starting off with the
so-called Foo Fighters that were
observed during World War two starting
in 1944 at least four different
countries had observed orbs glowing
lights of yellow red and orange color
following and chasing air
from the United States the Great Britain
Nazi Germany and even Imperial Japan and
I could have sworn that there was
something about a fifth country France
or Russia I never I wasn't able to
verify I didn't spend enough time
looking into it but here's the bottom
line these orbs were chasing aircraft
they were fired on in numerous occasions
to no success they were quite literally
able to outmaneuver machine gun fire
they would circle the aircraft they
would chase them and even follow them
for as much as 30 minutes on end in some
cases now the explanation for this based
on the Air Force is that well this was
maybe ball lightning which is of course
an unexplained phenomena and just does
not add up when you consider the fact
that ball lightning is a quick thing and
I mean when you have these objects
following aircraft for 30 minutes and
doing circles around them I mean that's
just that's just not the explanation
that doesn't make sense or even static
discharge off the wingtips in fact this
is the reason why we have static
discharges as you've seen on airplanes
to allow the static to discharge from
the airplane safely but that doesn't
make sense either guys I mean come on
really
you know these pilots aren't stupid and
they were from four different countries
and they all thought the same thing for
decades actually which is that it must
be top-secret enemy aircraft well that
turned out not to be true I mean here we
are seventy-three years later and
besides why don't we see this more often
why haven't we seen this in you know I
mean how many times have you flown and
you've never seen it you know glowing
orbs of bright color chasing your
aircraft or following you around or
doing circles around the aircraft now
let me jump into the second example the
1952 lights over Washington DC incident
this is pretty incredible it was
observed on two different radar systems
from Washington National Airport which
was the name of the airport at the time
and Andrews Air Force Base
both radars of both control towers
observe this they had objects moving
across the radar screen at over 7,000
miles an hour even doing 90-degree turns
at several hundred miles an hour oh and
real quick by the way when you research
this on your own this photo here is a
reanimation it's not real it came out a
few years ago that's what people witness
that's essentially what it looked like
but that is not a legitimate photograph
or video of it just to let you know but
this entire incident occurred over four
nights two back-to-back weekends at the
end of July in 1952 but what makes this
even more
interesting is that it was observed for
military pilots on the ground as well as
in the air civilian pilots and crews on
the ground as well as in the air on all
four different nights in fact it was so
serious that they launched fighter jets
p94 is in fact to go chase them down but
to no success they were even ordered to
shoot these things down but they
couldn't even run them down they had no
chance based on how fast these things
were moving and just like the incidents
from 1944 they were described as glowing
orbs they even had a press conference
about this at the Pentagon which was the
largest since World War two and it was
held by Major General John Samford now
the Air Force has stated multiple
explanations for this one of which was
that what you are seeing on radar even
though they determined that the radar
systems were functional and what
operating without error then it must be
well maybe it was related to a
temperature inversion but that's really
silly I mean yeah maybe that could cause
some issues with the radar systems but
what about all the pilots on the ground
as well as in the air for separate
nights that witnessed these events there
were chasing them down and described in
an epic detail so yeah the temperature
inversion thing is silly and it's just a
distraction
they've even suggested that it was
steamboats moving up the Potomac River
headed to Mountain Vernon which is just
ridiculous I mean that explanation the
bunks itself I mean how many pilots and
crew members and people witnessed this I
mean give me a break but here's a real
curveball in their story this was
witness as far away as Franklin Indiana
which is what nearly 600 miles away so
yeah it wasn't temperature inversion it
wasn't a steamboat clearly we're being
distracted guys and this is just along
the lines of what edgar mitchell said
quote it has been the subject of
disinformation in order to deflect
attention and create confusion so the
truth doesn't come out so what else
could it have been it's either aliens
beings from other planets
ETS whatever you want to call them or
top-secret technology it could have been
the x-15 there's many reasons why hell
even the Astro 71 Blackbird wasn't even
conceived on paper for seven years after
this event and didn't have his first
test flight for nearly a dozen years
after that but besides that I mean again
these things were observed moving at
several thousand miles an hour and doing
90-degree turns it's several hundred
miles an hour the human body could not
withstand that many G's so what else
could it be
oan I mean I don't know if drone
technology exists today that could do
those kind of maneuvers if there is his
top-secret but in 1952 I mean if that's
the case and we have been left in the
dark for far longer than we ever thought
possible and the implications of that
are
well disturbing I mean here we are
paying you know fuel at the pump record
high airfare prices what are based on
oil and gas and yet technology obviously
exists it doesn't run on that if I mean
if this is indeed top-secret technology
so either it's aliens or top-secret
technology either way the implications
are pretty disturbing the last example
is of course the 1997 Phoenix lights
incident this incident happened on March
13th 1997 and made headlines around the
world it was observed by thousands of
people all the way from Henderson Nevada
all the way down through through Phoenix
and Tucson Arizona in fact there's at
least 800 statements for witnesses that
observed a massive triangle shaped craft
that had five lights and many say was at
least a mile wide they said it was
absolutely silent it moved slowly and
the actual sheer size of it was just
breathtaking in fact even then Governor
v Symington has come out in the years
following stating that he is absolutely
convinced that it was an alien craft
from some other world I mean take it for
what it's worth but he was a captain in
the Air Force he later went on to become
a pilot
what makes it even more interesting is
that the big controversy is whether it
is military flares or not guys that is
part of the distraction this is exactly
what Edgar Mitchell was talking about
about disinformation and confusion
because those flares were witnessed at
what 10:00 p.m. when this whole event
started as early as 655 in Henderson
Nevada with Fein in Prescott Valley was
seen in Phoenix by thousands of people
hours before the flares and by the way
look at the photo you see at least seven
flares there we're an overwhelming
amount of the witnesses described five
lights not seven so that whole
discussion and debate on flares not
flares guys it was both but for people
to witness this event separately during
Twilight hours when there was still
visible light in the sky and they could
actually see the silhouette of a black
craft with five lights directly above
them what in the world was that and as
many people said at least a mile wide
Wow so what are the possibilities well
either alien craft
beings from other planets or top-secret
technology or both if you don't buy into
the alien argument you have to ask
yourself well is the top-secret
technology possible when you're talking
in 1944 what seventy-three years ago or
1952 lights over DC beam 65 years ago
look into the details guys come to your
own conclusions all I know is that the
truth is stranger than fiction I'll
leave it at that
I'm Jimmy this is bright insight like
and subscribe leave me a comment let me
know what your thoughts are and share
any other incidences that are worthy of
mention because I obviously left out
many others that are very compelling so
I'll leave it at that
take care everybody